hello and welcome to this video playing
my way from Norway and is going to play
the my way variation with Bishop g5 yeah
so let's see what happens in this game
and only her play 'if i yam but them Wow
normally up lately five but you always
place this funky line in the sicilian
wow I don't want to get checkmated here
on a Quincy 7 I like 97 made or
something like that what the heck
and maybe just should be three here
right he's are taking a seven
hmm i think just Bishop e3 but i don't
know maybe he finds some further wacky
possibility yeah it takes a seven just
like that I don't know I can take any
force and I know then 97 I'm getting
confused here a lot so what to do maybe
b6 huh yeah maybe this just cover sm
well that it wasn't exactly refutation
of his line instead of age six I
probably should go a six ended that
feels a lot better okay so let's see I
mean this is this is this probably isn't
terribly bad but the opposition is just
far too weird for my taste
okay I should have played a 6 first
remark about stuff like this that's its
strong be sure there was just a strong
move I guess
I really really really dislike to play
night to a six mad no move had no other
moves and he he does not have to play
Knights his d6 now right away you can
also also play and check other things
this is of course just better for him so
okay and Bishop b5 is also coming ah but
a position
should be five coming around and this
this he can actually if he likes just
take and plane I'd be five but hmm
amazing that mean age six was just
really really bad
just F 30 so I don't have a move I mean
it's it's amazing how bad this is
upon the point the bishop on d6 this is
one of the most annoying pieces i
remember the only little hope is that
he's taking quite some time here yeah I
can't play me five here i can do that
but i probably will cost a pawn in the
long run
b5 technically I can play b5 here good
move
you
can only hope for some time in use
problems on this on his hand on one on
his end oh my goodness cannot cannot
speak and yeah wow really wants to kill
me now take here than h5 I guess
pawn takes going back okay is there some
way signal ticking ticking there's
probably also totally rotten
amazingly bad position 23 no time
warning I just has Bishop t6 here can
just pay go back check
Oh black resigns Wow it totally killed
me after age 6 h-6 is just terrible it
seems I added that leads to very awkward
positions at least I should just go 860
I think yeah just a six just a six and
we get a normal position where the
bishop on g5 is looking funny yeah this
is really really bad it's really bad
move
this is a funny-looking move but he can
do this I mean I cannot take any way I
here with the Queen that's 927 I think I
have to do what I what I did and now i'm
sitting in this may be a six but this is
also not good I mean he can just go in
height a seven and this is a good
position for wide after after taking him
just a an open Sicilian way up yeah I've
given to see eight bishop somehow and I
mean this is better than the game but it
also didn't feel very nice all right
this is murderously strong we shouldn't
be 70 assembly didn't think about that
the night that the bishop might move
again I have to have to kick the night
back and play this position which is
yeah looking like yeah this is not good
for black but it leads it's some kind of
game yeah it's like weird b6 move
somewhere here well well it's playable
at least and this must not playable
after this i'm just in terrible shape
and all this is brutal queen dee fries
strong you cannot cannot get out of this
stuff Bishop a six that it's a good
computer suggestion let's trade
something but it's it's just not a
player position with this with this
Jen I just there was a total murder
edits it's really a strange move our
Quincy 7 cannot be bad I think I Thea I
have to go a 6cm this is a con variation
with a weird bishop on g5 this should be
ok for black I don't see I mean he
probably goes here and then this is a
request this is something that we had
before and something like this is
actually really good for black and I
think we had this in earlier games I but
I didn't I was just thinking he goes
here I wasn't registering that 95 is a
lot stronger and then the position is
bad for black Wow ok thanks for watching